it's really no secret why Joe Biden
picked Cala Harris as his vice president
it certainly wasn't based on her
remarkable intellect or extensive
qualifications no it was her gender and
her skin color here's a refresher from
Joe Biden
himself I would pick a woman to be my
vice president are you committed to
naming a black woman as your vice
presidential running
mate I am not committed to naming any
but the people I've named and among them
there are four black
women well that's apparently new Cala
the vice president sounding completely
confused when she was asked this by the
media he came to decision that he needed
to choose a black woman how should it
matter does it matter that that
narrative has existed that Biden needed
to choose someone or who who was a black
person and should it matter I don't
think I understand your question does it
matter that that kind of narrative
around Biden needed to choose a black
woman as a running mate still exist and
has hovered over that selection or it
happened
I don't I don't think I understand you I
honestly don't understand your question
he chose a black woman that woman is me
so I I don't know that anything lingers
about what he should choose he has
chosen you know if all we get out of the
Biden Administration is this one clip
then uh it will have all been worth it
um and I want to get to the New York
Times the fact that the New York Times
is like twisting the knife here but
first Greg the the most amazing thing
and this is the problem with identity
politics is and and it's it's so much
worse with identity politics but it's
also true with affirmative action when
you set up a system where everything is
based on race even if you succeed you
have to I almost sort of feel sorry for
her and and her confusion here that
people are are talking about this
because even if you succeed under
affirmative action you and everybody
around you is wondering what's this all
about yeah that's the flaw ined in
embedded in the diversity hire if you
are hired based on skin color people
will think you were hired on skin color
especially if there's no other reason
because she hasn't exemplified any type
of confidence but when you view that I
mean I'm sorry that's an art piece a
performance art piece to be appreciated
as if she is playing the role of an
ambivalent soulless bureaucrat it's
beautiful the sad irony is that this was
supposed to be a big step for women of
color but it was a big step backwards
and the reason why she's giggling is
because she can't believe she actually
got hired she finds it funny herself she
her she is the worst spokeswoman for
diversity since Liz
Warren she's the victim now she's the
victim vitim and you're the oppressor
Charlie so always um so Kaylee but I I
have to say I mean I'm kind I was sort
of shocked I was impressed by some of
the questions the New York Times I mean
somebody didn't get a memo or somebody's
just getting the memo or what's going on
here yeah I mean it seems like there's a
broader takedown mission on the part of
some Lucid leftist journalists in the
New York Times included Washington Post
who realize oh wait let's look at our
own poll our New York Times Sienna poll
which shows Joe Biden and KLA Harris
losing to Donald Trump I mean she was
picked the New York Times was told by
Harry Reid quote they are our most loyal
voters black women I think that black
women deserved a black vice presidential
candidate so they were told about this
identity politics and he asked the
question kamla has failed at her mission
she was supposed to bring in black women
according to Harry Reid well
22% of black Americans are voting for
Donald Trump in the New York Times
Sienna poll over 8% which is what he got
in 2020 and if he was to achieve those
numbers no Republican candidate in the
last half century has gotten more than
12% of black voters so she failed at the
border failed at passing voting rights
legislation failed at winning black
voters and as Donald Trump says he's the
least racist person to ever run for
office I've heard mentioned that before
and and and Camala Harris is 16 points
underwater sure on popularity um what
would you uh say is her number one
accomplishment I I need to go through a
bunch of things first
so no one thinks who who's being an
honest broker about that Donald Trump is
going to get 22% of the black vote not
because he didn't do better than other
Republican candidates but because that
would mean that the entire electoral
system in America has been upended in 4
years um while the man is facing four
indictments in 91 felony counts look
at I'm just I'm listen I I look
forward to talking about it after the
November election the man is not getting
22% of the vote they also had him
winning the youth vote please I have a
bridge to sell you okay politics is
all what
that that one went over my head too
don't worry well at least we share that
oh I get it now okay um all of politics
is identity politics I don't think
anyone is going to tell me genuinely
that Sarah Palin was the most qualified
pick for vice president in 08 John
McCain needed a lady and he picked a
lady Mike Pence and Donald Trump have
zero in common except that they wanted
to win the presidency and what did
Donald Trump get from Mike Pence he got
a nice conservative Evangelical man that
would make a philanderer seem palatable
to the Republican base and then he was
able to win representation giving groups
representation does not mean that it is
a hire without Merit I went back through
KLA Harris's record today because I knew
we were going to talk about it she was
Da she was attorney general in
California then she was a Senator things
like the back on track program the
homeowner Bill of Rights what she did to
get uh Proposition 8 overturned in
California after it went to the Supreme
Court and then she married the first gay
couple once it uh the marriages were
resumed and if you listened to her
questioning of
Trump's nominees when she was a Senator
she destroyed Bill bar there up there so
saying that this woman was not qualified
or that her candidacy was not without
Merit I think is completely unfair and
denigrating the woman and I think she
should have used this as an opportunity
to talk about how important it is that
underserved groups are represented that
it doesn't make her not worthy of the
job she
couldn't she's not in he look what she
should have done and she doesn't even
have the political Savvy to turn it
around that shows how inep she is okay
when she's supposed to be so political
you turn it around and you embrace it
and you say yes I am proud to be the
first woman vice president proud to be
the first black female vice president
and yes I have the I have the
credentials da attorney general United
States Senator yes I'm proud to be the
tip of the spear in this changing of
history in America yeah and you don't
want you too stupid to even do that but
here's the thing here's the thing that
that I think is so sad about it she
truly didn't understand the question
right she didn't understand it and she
didn't have forget the political Savvy
she didn't have the intelligence to
comprehend what was being asked of her
and by the way I don't think she was so
great in asking questions your staff
gives you questions to ask when she was
a Senator she was you let me explain
something she did a lot of things that
got her up and Beyond The Regular Guy in
politics okay she used her sex in ways
that got her to the next level let's not
kid each other and and I would like to
clarify one thing all politics is not
identity politics uh it's the lowest
form of politics and if you want to know
what the extension the furthest
extension of identity politics is look
out in the streets and see this rioting
o over uh Palestine and Israel that's
identity politics in its worst form and
2016 is a perfect example where uh where
identity politics was trumped by issues
and and that's what we should be it's
very easy no offense to you but it's
obvious for a white man to sit here and
say that identity politics is the lowest
form of politics you have not answer why
Donald
Trump as a white man I as a woman I
agree with that you ever did you ever
get anything because you woman no I
worked my ass no of course you did but
do you don't think matter to your
candidacy that you were a woman we have
to go but and why you won we have to go
but Martin Luther King Martin Luther
King also believed that identity
politics was the lowest form of politics
up next is Joe Biden ruining Oreos
shrinkflation is taking a big bite out
of the iconic cookie hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else